اريد ان اسمع منك رايك فيما ذكره القيادي
في كتائب القسام عن ما جرى في عمليه
الاستدراج والتفخيخ
وا القنص والقتل
لمجموعه الجنود قبل ايام في
المغازي يعني اعتقد يعني كانت عمليه نوعيه
بامتياز واعتقد انها مرت بمراحل
متعدده المرحله الاولى وهي الاعداد
الجيد للمقاتلين الذين سيشاركون في هذه
العمليه وخاصه يعني لابد ان يكون مستوى
عالي من التدريب لغه مشتركه يتفاهمون
عليها لانه في الميدان لا مجال للشرح
للكلمات الطويله انما بالاشاره سيتم
التفاهم التواصل والاتصال فيما بينهم
اتفقوا عليه وهناك مرحله الرصد والتتبع
وانا يعني بالامس تحدثت من هنا وقلت ان
هذه العمليه اعد لها فتره طويله فتره
زمنيه طويله ليست يعني وليده الساعه لانها
بحاجه الى رصد وتتبع طويل المدى جمع
المعلومات ايضا بحاجه
الى يعني اناس قادرين على ان يفهموا لغه
العدو الاسرائيلي اشارات الجنود
الاسرائيليين ماذا يحملون وواضح من من
تقرير المقاومه الفلسطينيه بانهم تعرفوا
على وحده الهندسه من خلال
الاشارات ومن خلال ما تحمل من معدات وهذا
طبعا واضح يدل على عمق وعي المقاتلين
الفلسطينيين توزيع الواجبات ايضا من المهم
قبل العمليه ان يكون هناك توزيع للواجبات
بين الافراد كل وله دوره التوقيتات
التوقيتات واولويات الاهداف ايه هناك ثلاث
اهداف كانت موجوده المباني الجنود
الاسرائيليين الاليات ايهما كان الاولى ان
ان يتم اطلاق النار عليه بالامس يعني سئلت
وقلت انه الاساس هو المبنى لماذا لانه
المبنى اولا العدد الاكبر من الجنود
الاسرائيليين موجودين فيه وهم وهم منظورين
للمقاومين الفلسطينيين ولكن المقاومين غير
منظورين لهم في حين ان الموجودين في
الحمايه
لواء واصف لواء واصف اسمح لي اريد ان نوه
الى الخبر العاجل الذي نشاهده على الشاشه
القناه الثاله عش الاسرائيليه عن مكتب
نتنياهو محادثات جاده ومستمره بين مسؤولين
اسرائيليين ومصريين بينهم مدير المخابرات
عباس كامل والقناه الثالثه عش عن مكتب
نتنياهو محاوله الاتصال مع الرئيس السيسي
كانت على خلفيه نيه اسرائيل العمل على
محور فيلاد
اذا هذه العواجل تابعناها على الشاشه
واعود لضيف لواء واصف وهذه العمليه نتحدث
اكثر عن هذه
عمليه التوصيف الدقيق من قبل القياده
القيادي في القسام لهذه
العمليه يعني
عمليه البقاء في المكان رغم عمليه التمشيط
من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه التي ظنت بانها
قامت بعمليه التمشيط
بصوره كامله الى اي
درجه يعني ما هي العوامل التي تلعب
لصالح الطرف المقاوم الفلسطيني على الارض
خاصه فيما يتعلق بعمليه القتال المعقده
هناك يعني نحن نتحدث عن مقاوم اعد نفسه
فتره طويله يعني يوم عمليه طوفان الاقصى
المواصفات للمقاتلين كانت على مستوى عالي
من التدريب ومن المهاره الميدانيه
والقتاليه وجمع المعلومات والامنيه
والاستخباري الاساس اختي العزيزه في كل
العمليات القتاليه ان المقاوم الفلسطيني
يعرف هذا العدو بادق تفاصيله فلذلك هو اعد
نفسه ليواجه الجندي الاسرائيلي بتكتيكات
بخططه بقدراته القتاليه الميدانيه ولذلك
هو حينما وصل الى المنطقه او اختار
المنطقه وكان يعرف تماما ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي في ذهنه ان هذه المنطقه مؤمنه
ولا يمكن للمقاومين الفلسطينيين ان يصلوا
اليها بدليل انها قصفت قصفت اكثر من مره
قصفت بالطائرات وقصفت بالمدفعيه وحينما
تقدمت القوات الاسرائيليه سواء كان وحدات
الهندسه او الوحدات الراجله تقدمت قبلها
الدبابات فلذلك يعني الجيش الاسرائيلي كان
يعتبر ان هذه المنطقه امنه ولا يمكن ل
المقاومين الفلسطينيين ان يتواجدوا فيها
وانا بتقديري هذا يعني سر سر قدره
المقاومين الفلسطينيين على اختيار الهدف
بدقه متناهيه رغم خطورته يعني في تصنيف
هذا الهدف بالنسبه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
يعني ياخذ يعني درجه خطير جدا وبحاجه الى
يعني دقه متنا لا متناهيه في اختيار كل
خطوه من الخطوات التي قاموا بتنفيذها نحن
شاهدنا شريط فيديو صور ولكن على ارض
الواقع الصعوبات التي واجهت المقاتلين
الفلسطينيين اعتقد انها لا مجال لحصرها
ولكن تفوق العقل الفلسطيني على الاسرائيلي
تفوقت الشجاعه الفلسطينيه على السلوك
الاسرائيلي معنويات المقاتلين الذين صبروا
وصمدوا وانتظروا وكان هناك مجال ان ان
يطلقوا النار على اكثر من هدف ولكنهم
استطاعوا ان يعطوا اولويه قصوى للا
الاهداف التي ادت الى هذه النتيجه وادت
الى يعني واذا
نتائج واذا ما اردنا ان نتحدث عن نتائج
الاثر الاثر العسكري
الاثر على الميدان والاثر ايضا بالنسبه
للردع والاثر المعنوي النفسي بالنسبه
للطرف الاسرائيلي يعني يعني تحدثت عن
الردع دعينا نتحدث عن الردع ما هو الردع
الردع عند الجيش الاسرائيلي
هو ان يقصف باقصى قصوى عنده ان يضرب باقصى
قصوى عنده ان ان يستخدم العصى الغليظه قدر
المستطاع بمعنى يجب ان يعني يصل الى وعي
المقابل سواء كان فلسطيني او غير فلسطيني
انه لا جدوى من قتال الاسرائيلي هذه لغاها
الفلسطيني حقيقه وهذه ايضا عقيده
جابوتنسكي التي منذ العام 1988 4 وهي تقول
ما لم نحصل عليه بالقوه سنحصل عليه بمزيد
من القوه ولكن الفلسطيني اليوم بعقيدته
الجديده يقول ل الاسرائيلي هذه لا تنفع مع
المقاومين الفلسطينيين الانذار الذي يعتمد
عليه ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي انه لا يجب ان
يكون لديه مخزون من المعلومات سواء كانت
من الاقمار الصناعيه او من الرقابه
الارضيه او من اي وسيله امنيه واستخبارات
هذه الان مفقوده المقاومه الفلسطينيه برع
في اخفاء نفسه في تمويه نفسه في عدم قدره
الجيش الاسرائيلي على تجميع معلومات عن
هذه المقاومه وقدراتها وتكتيكاتها الحسم
الاسرائيلي اعتاد على ان يحسم بسرعه لانه
لا يوجد عنده عمق استراتيجي عمق جغرافي
فبالتالي هو الان ايضا يمارس هذه العقيده
في قطاع غزه بمعنى انه يريد ان يحسن بسرعه
ولكن المقاوم يحرمه من هذه العقيده ايضا
فبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن نظريات اسرائيليه
فشلت في مواجهه المقاومين الفلسطينيين
والمقاومين الفلسطينيين برعوا في ان
يواجهوا الجيش الاسرائيلي في نقاط ضعفه
اذا المقاومه الفلسطيني يستخدم نقاط قوته
مقابل نقاط ضعف العدو